how did Texas come about hello my name
is too cute I design rocket-propelled
clothes I came to earth because I am
fascinated by your shoes there is no
such thing on my planet I have a great
idea I will design rocket-propelled
shoes Europeans love shoes I will make
my shoes in the European Union but if I
set up a business I'll have to pay taxes
what's the whole idea of tax about
anyway when did people in Europe come up
with the idea of taxes press the red
button and go back in time to find out
[Music]
you are in Athens capital of ancient
Greece when Athens had to go to war
someone had a brilliant idea every
Athenian citizen would pay some money to
the state to buy weapons and look after
the army
this was an early kind of tax called ice
fora after the war ended the citizens
stopped paying this tax and sometimes
the state could pay back the tax with
stuff they'd captured during the war
very clever the Roman Empire invented
all sorts of taxes it was very expensive
running such a big Empire one of the
first taxes was called moon era which
means duty or obligation it was paid by
wealthy people to contribute to the
Roman Empire some of the taxes invented
during the Roman Empire we still pay in
Europe property tax customs duties
general tax on sales of goods
inheritance tax those Romans must have
been clever half taxes always been good
for the people
[Music]
Wow I have horns the Vikings had a
cunning idea they invaded England and
refused to leave unless the English paid
them a guest fee the English didn't
think it was very funny
the Vikings thought it was hilarious
back in the Roman Empire - what's that
smell human pee or urine if you're being
polite was used to make leather and to
clean white robes Tanner's and laundry
women bought bucket loads from public
urinals in Rome's great sewer system
Emperor Vespasian realized he could get
lots of money by taxing it
beard tax introduced by Tsar Peter the
first of Russia it was paid by men who
grew a beard because it wasn't
fashionable in Western Europe and Tsar
Peter wanted Russia to be European I
just can't believe that
[Music]
England's King William the third had a
great idea rich people had big houses
with lots of glass windows so in 1696 he
introduced a window tax the bigger the
house the more windows it had and the
more tax the owner would pay that was so
cunning
[Music]
from our journey through time I learned
the citizens have had to pay taxes for
some crazy reasons I understand citizens
had to pay some unfair taxes when it was
a king or a few rich people who made the
rules it got better when citizens could
elect a government to manage taxes for
them who is in charge of all the money
collected in taxes that's an important
job
how do citizens know the money is spent
fairly in towns and cities there is the
local council my uncle is the mayor of
our town there are 50,000 people living
there the council talked about what to
do would have hats money and move out to
the side and a team of people to
organizer who is on the Town Council any
citizen who lives here can stand for
election as a councillor is a good way
to contribute to your community this is
a country in the EU does it have a
council to this EU country has 50
million citizens as a national
parliament which makes decisions for the
whole country there is a prime minister
who bleeds two governments and other
ministers for different departments like
Foreign Affairs and Industry and
agriculture the members of parliament
talk about everything and voters side on
new laws and how to spend our tax money
they spend the tax money on national
services there is someone in charge of
the whole European Union that's a huge
job he has a council and the Parliament
the servants work organizing 28
countries and 500 million citizens no
wonder it's so important to pay our
taxes now you have explained the taxes
we pay don't see much at all for all the
services and all the work that's done
everyone benefits their whole life
please explain your benefit as soon as
you're born through health care and
social services then you get your
education and leisure when are your
trials and when you have your own family
you really appreciate everything you get
from the local council and the state
what would happen if a taxpayer decided
not to pay tax because he doesn't use
these services he's strong and healthy
so he doesn't need a doctor he has never
been robbed so he has never needed the
police to find the thief he doesn't have
children so he doesn't need a school for
them but he does use the roads and the
trains
he wants his country to be safe he wants
to play sports and go to the theatre he
wants a clean City and a safe city maybe
doesn't know how much Fanny who gets
from taxi pays so paying tax is about
contributing to society not just buying
a service I see what a good feeling that
gives me tax is that we citizens pay are
not just to respond to our personal
needs and benefit our family directly
each contribution house support everyone
at some point we all need education
health care justice and be safe to enjoy
our lives in a peaceful country
can you show me anything that taxes paid
for that shock is my mum's new business
she got some money and lots of free
advice to help her get started in that
block of offices of the Town Council
they organized all the public services
for the town everything is paid out of
taxes I live in that house my dad runs
that hotel we pay local taxes to get our
rubbish collectors and for the library
and my school the streetlights
the roads and pavements Mendez so it's
the cities that get all the benefit from
taxes no silly to cute
there are no public services here
cleaner and clean environment managing
the national park local bus service and
a car park for visitors village school
health center post office oh yes I see
now taxes go a long way can you show me
more public services yes the railways
can take you to the next station or
right across Europe charmese dare to
give our whole country safe please
protectors end account and catch
criminals okay you've convinced me